the GOP lesser-known debate will be
happening but we're not going to be
watching it so if you guys do want to
see it just adds up around nine that's
what it's gonna be on we're not going to
be covering it because Fox News is
threatening to sue anybody who tries to
rebroadcast it and I do think we have a
fair use grounds in commenting on one of
the most vital news stories in this
nation but I must admit
s someone will turn there turn their
volume down wasn't me this time uh-oh
so uh Tucker Carlson
is going to be interviewing Donald Trump
people he's already released a little
demo snippet where he asks Trump if he
thinks we're headed towards Civil War ha
he asks Trump if he fears assassination
and so we'll we'll talk about that as
well as why I think the GOP debate is
completely irrelevant I gotta be honest
without Trump there what's the point and
Trump's team has already put out
statement basically saying he's won the
debate because all they're going to do
is talk about him which is basically
true and honestly yo if you want to see
Nikki Haley with Mike Pence about stuff
by all means do it but I just don't
think it's going to be relevant to your
or anyone else's life